D
IS CUT OFF FROM ACCESS TO U.S.
OFFICIALS.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT SAYS IT IS
WORKING DILIGENTLY ON HER
INDICATION.
NEW CONCERNS TONIGHT ABOUT THE
FATES OF THREE AMERICANS BEING
DETAINED IN RUSSIA.
BASKETBALL SCAR BRITTNEY GRINER,
WE ARE NOW LEARNING, HAS BEEN
HELD FOR THREE WEEKS, SINCE
FEBRUARY 17th, ACCORDING TO HER
HOMETOWN CONGRESSMAN COLIN
ALLRED.
SHE'S HAD NO ACCESS TO ANYONE
FROM THE U.S. GOVERNMENT, HE
SAYS.
IT'S NOT EVEN CLEAR WHERE GRINER
IS BEING HELD.
>> SHE SHOULD BE ABLE TO COME
HOME AND NOT BE SWEPT UP IN THIS
LARGER CONFLICT THAT IS
HAPPENING.
>> Reporter: GRINER WAS ARRESTED
IN A MOSCOW AIRPORT WITH WHAT
OFFICERS SAY WAS CANNABIS OIL,
THEY ACCUSED HER OF SMUGGLING
NARCOTICS.
THEY ARE WORRIED THE TWO-TIME
OLYMPIC MEDALIST STAR AS AN
ATHLETE COULD WORK AGAINST HER,
AS IS HER SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
SHE IS GAY AND MARRIED.
RUSSIA HAS STRICT LBGTQ LAWS.
>> WHAT I EXPECT RUSSIANS TO USE
THE FACT THAT HER SURVIVE MAKING
PUBLIC STATEMENTS.
THESE ARE BEING REPORTED IN THE
MEDIA AND SOCIAL MEDIA OF PROP
BEGAN PROPAGANDAIZATION RIGHTS.
THAT COULD BE ANOTHER REASON TO
DETAIN HER.
>> Reporter: TREVOR REED
DESCRIBED THEMSELVES AS PANICKED
OVER HIS CONDITION FOLLOWING A
CALL WITH HIM YESTERDAY, REED'S
PARENTS SAY HIS PHYSICAL
CONDITION HAS TAKEN A TURN FOR
THE WORSE, THAT HAD ALREADY BEEN
DIRE.
>> HE SAYS HE IS COUGHING
CONSTANTLY, COUGHING UP BLOOD
THROUGHOUT THE DAY.
FEVER OVER 100 DEGREES AND HAS
PAIN IN HIS CHEST.
JUST ALL THE SIGNS OF
TUBERCULOSIS.
>> REED'S PARENT SAID HE WAS
GOING TO BE TAKEN TO A HOSPITAL.
YESTERDAY HE WAS SUMMON MID-AND
QUOTE AUTHORITIES MAY SEND HIM
BACK TO SOLITARY CONFINEMENT,
INSTEAD.
REED AND FELLOW FORMER U.S.
MARINE PAUL WHELEN WERE DETAINED
IN RUSSIA SINCE WELL BEFORE THE
INVASION OF UKRAINE.
WELL WHELAN'S SISTER GAVE US AN
EXPLANATION.
>> HE IS DOING AS WELL AS HE CAN
IN A LABOR CAMP IN RUSSIA.
>> Reporter: THESE THREE
AMERICANS GIVE TENSION OVER THE
CONFLICT IN UKRAINE ARE
INTENSIFYING.
>> HOW DIFFICULT IS IT TO GET
THEM OUT AT THIS POINT?
IS IT POSSIBLE?
>> WE'RE AT SUCH A DIFFERENT
LEVEL OF CONFRONTATION WITH
RUSSIA RIGHT NOW.
THEY REALLY ARE BEING USED AS
PAWNS.
HE'S NOT GOI